a recent report outlined how hispanic
workers continue to experience a
shortage of good jobs although hispanics
tend to have a high employment rate
across the u.s certain nationalities
tend to have a wage gap when it comes to
gender and ethnicity
a little bit scared because you know
it's a little different maria castro
recently began working at this
restaurant near desert inn and valley
view before i work and for the 15 years
for one restaurant and this
is bad
and this is new for me but
i'm really happy she says this new
opportunity also came with a higher wage
according to a recent report from the
center for american progress hispanic
workers particularly those from mexico
guatemala honduras and el salvador face
the largest pay gaps compared to
non-hispanics working in these fields i
always try to look around you know
what's the average salary with what the
restaurants are paying restaurant owner
eduardo gonzalez says offering
competitive wages to employees is hard
for small businesses but he says it's
necessary to keep the staff from walking
out if the employee is good i mean of
course i'm going to pay right away
around the door like hey i'm going to
give you 20 dollars an hour if someone
comes they show their work and said you
know what i can pay you this because i
want to keep a good employee than be
switching employees every two weeks
latino communities were one of the
hardest hit by the covet pandemic
according to the report it also states
those with darker skin say they face
discrimination and have a steeper climb
to the middle class castro disagrees and
says it's all about working hard to get
ahead it's a lot of work for everywhere
yes
you want to work come and try
well here in the u.s there are more than
60 million latinos majority mexicans
puerto ricans and cubans which is
similar a similar breakdown of the
nationalities here in southern nevada